qui aurait pu prédire la vague
d'inflation ainsi déclenchée où la crise
climatique aux effets spectaculaires
encore cet été dans notre pays voici
maintenant que le réchauffement global
de la planète est commencé
général réchauffement de deux ou trois
degrés de la température de l'atmosphère
d'infusion fusion d'une énorme quantité
de glace polaire aussi bien au sud konor
les glaces de montagne il risque de
réchauffement donc à cause de
réchauffement deux trois degrés de
moyenne suffisent le problème est
extrêmement sérieux il est certain que
lorsque la concentration gaz carbonique
de l'atmosphère aura doublé on se
prépare un changement climatique et
changement climatique il a commencé si
vous voulez dès que les hommes ont
commencé à brûler du bois du charbon du
pétrole c'est-à-dire des 1850 la Terre
va se réchauffer et pour l'instant on ne
le voit à peine et ce que nous ne
pouvons pas dire encore que le climat a
changé parce que l'essentiel de la
chaleur qui se dégage rentre dans
l'océan ce n'est rien aujourd'hui par
rapport à ce qui va se passer dans 5 ans
ou dans 100 ans
[Musique]